[Música]
já pensaram que hoje é um dia mais calmo
durante a nossa vida profissional
o dia mais calmo do resto da nossa vida
profissional porque porque depois de
hoje todos os dias vão ser cada via mais
rápido as coisas vão acontecer mais
veloz vamos ter de mudar muito mais
rápido
já estamos a mudar muito mais rápido do
que estamos a mudar há uns anos e tudo
vai começar a acelerar acelerar acelerar
hoje estamos no dia mais calmo do resto
das nossas vidas profissionais
isto é por causa da crise econômica
acham que é por causa da crise econômica
pois não é é por outro motivo que eu vou
tratar de explicar hoje aqui nesta
palestra
imaginem eu vou explicar de uma forma
diferente
imagine um amigo meu chamado velho era
uma pessoa de sucesso
uma pessoa que está a passar tendo dois
filhos têm dois negócios muito criou um
negócio pequenino que chamava o smiles
que o negócio estava a funcionar muito
bem e dava muito sobre isso se eles olha
vou criar um outro o primeiro era uma
cafeteria e eu saí na televisão então eu
vou criar um outro negócio que um outro
maior e tudo estava a correr bem e um
dia para ser um telefonema era sua
mulher disseram que as coisas não
estavam a correr tão bem como eu pensava
a realidade é que depois desse
telefonema e continuar a falar
ele entrou em crise é uma crise para ele
uma crescente e namoradas
era uma crise ou não era uma crise
a realidade é que depois daquela cena a
realidade que eu tinha era muito
diferente da realizada 500
então quando mudamos a realidade é que
estamos a passar um momento mau ea
realidade que vem depois é muito franca
é uma crise
foi uma mudança uma transformação
então vou pedir que levantem as nossas
mãos quem acha que realmente quando a
situação que temos depois de passar um
momento mau é muito diferente
quem acha que isso não é uma crise é uma
transformação por favor bancos mãos são
tímidas mas há muito se levantar as mãos
então quando a situação de partida é
muito diferente é se não é uma crise
quando nós estamos a passar de uma
situação econômica era de uma forma está
a chegar para uma forma totalmente
diferente quando passarmos de uma forma
que agora vou explicar
era uma forma de trabalhar que era
triangular e gostamos numa forma quer
circular lentamente estamos a passar uma
crise ou é uma transformação que vou
experimentar com costa
se você me permitem experimentar e
conhecer o experimento muito rápido
porque temos muito pouco tempo
então vou ter dinheiro só vamos fazer um
experimento cinco segundos
vou pedir que se ponham de pé por favor
quem vai ser muito rápida
eu vou encontrar o trecho quando 43
ainda fazer uma coisa muito simples que
é olhar para trás e dar um abraço
confessou que tem mesmo por trás nosso
ganho então 123
ok não estava a conseguir muito bem
estou encantada mas não está a conseguir
agora vamos fazer essa voltem a olhar
pra frente
igor passará em vez de uma ordem de
pouco tem a fazer é passar para vocês um
desafio que o desafio é também em cinco
segundos depois de golear 123 inventar
que todo o pessoal que está na sala de
espera sala alguém pode ser dois três
pessoas em um dois três
o que aconteceu é que vocês conseguiram
esta solução muito rápido porque agora
não estavam todas as áreas e levanta a
bola no que está a acontecer não podem
sentar se quiserem entrar para história
pé que aconteceu no primeiro caso porque
eu dei pra vocês é uma ordem
então quando nos dá uma ordem nós temos
de seguir um processo que o processo é o
que parece esse processo
o que aconteceu é que esse processo
vocês viram que não conseguiam fazer
no segundo caso o que eu passei pra
vocês é um desafio
eles foram vocês quem se coordenaram
para solucionar essa feira e todos
conseguiram porque porque não penso
mesmo uma pessoa do que dos 150 pessoas
que estão aqui agora tal são mais
capazes de solucionar dos anos 50 do que
um ano antes trabalhava nos de uma forma
linear onde o pessoal nos dava ordens e
temos de cumprir essas ordens e agora
estamos a trabalhar de uma forma mais
coordenada motorista frio se ponha o pé
por favor
outra vez e agora vai responder com o
vosso corpo como eles podem com o corpo
serjão uma das situações que vou dizer
não para um lado está a outra vaga outro
lado e vou explicar agora quais são
roque
se nosso trabalho hoje em dia estão a
responder a fazer as coisas que dizem os
nossos chefs com o processo crime são as
chances do expresso que vai pra que lado
se nosso trabalho hoje em dia tem de ser
vocês quem a topper soluções os métodos
e os chefes o que se estava a passar e
sofreu sete objetivos por favor vai para
lá é galego não sabem do estado
ok então se o vosso trabalho é seguir
mesmo certinho certinho o que dizem os
chefes com o processo para que lado se
não pra este então força ea grande
maioria de vocês está aí pra louca para
o lugar onde estão os que têm de pensar
por que porque a realidade é que antes
tínhamos uma forma de trabalhar onde
havia alguém que pensava que era o chefe
dos chefes e o resto obedecíamos que
nesta forma triangular
repetimos e agora estamos numa forma de
trabalhar com de a maioria tem de ser
criativo mas não o santa entrou e eu
vamos fazer uma outra estamos rápidos
quem nos nossos trabalhos em nossos
trabalhos continua a ter os mesmos
colegas de trabalho - companheiros que a
dos imensos e não olhe não tiveram
nenhum novo companheiro vão pra lá e
hoje que tiveram companheiros novos de
trabalho da equipe está nos últimos 12
meses mais impressionada estão a ir mais
pra lá está até companheiros nós porque
porque no sistema anterior de trabalho o
habitual que era o habitual era
continuar sempre as nossas equipas de
trabalho e que não estava hoje em dia
não hoje está a alterar tudo estamos a
alterar muita coisa mas vou pedir que
mais em book 300 e tal e qual os pés em
boquim quem ache que em boquim
a informação está no site são os
empregados de um pouquinho quem coloca
lá as mensagens quem coloca é as fotos
do hotel heetal um prelado quem ache que
em boquim quem está preencher toda a
informação do site são os clientes
ganham pra que lembrem os hotéis são
clientes de um pouquinho
os hotéis tios o tanque os que viajam
tanto um pouquinho então sei quem coloca
informação do site
as comemorações tal são os clientes por
outro lado cessar os empregados até lá o
pessoal está a pensar
ok só pra que tanto isso igor lembrem a
mesma coisa está a sofrer como facebook
com vergonha b com o uberaba são os
clientes que estão a preencher
informação e quem está a tomar muitas
razões pela fácil porque porque até
agora nós temos uma estrutura piramidal
com deus que estavam por baixo
eram empregados e obedeciam chefes e
agora estamos em modelos de trabalho
onde estamos a trabalhar também com os
nossos clientes nossos clientes estão
envolvidos nas áreas de trabalho cria
uma informação muito interessante este
não faz falta se podem sentar não faz
falta que cemo que se mediam só pra
dizer que em uma loja tradicional só pra
que pensa assim
geralmente você tem de vigiar mais da
metade das crianças para uma loja de
piscinas alterar qualquer coisa nessa
loja mas noutros negócios como por
exemplo na mas um só cão 1% os clientes
valor negativo
eles estão a trocar de ares e olha como
o cliente tem de trocar qualquer
coisinha que trocas
aqui não pode se continuar a vender 1
por cento
faz 30 por cento que está a acontecer
nos negócios tradicionais era mais
piramidal e quem estava realmente a a
passar bem a estrutura do negócio era o
chefe eo resto está a manter uma vida
sem empregados que não era muito bom e
agora nestes negócios têm de estar todos
muito satisfeitos clientes empregados
estavam sendo um negócio cair porque de
alguma forma estamos a passar de uma
estrutura que era mais estável mas pra
mim gal a passar uma outra estrutura
circular que é diferente
isso também tem a ver com a nossa
formação porque nós temos estruturas
onde um professor é quem sabe quem passa
a mensagem para os outros e os que estão
por baixo
só tem de repetir nos testes e validar
são capazes de repetir e agora estamos
em outra formação que nos permita não
ser pessoa mais criativo que consiga
fazer coisas novas e o problema é que
não temos muitas informações porque
todos nós transformamos numa estrutura
criminal e eu não podia conseguir não
poder prometer
a minha própria toca você é a única
pessoa que estava falar o que vocês vão
falar e é por isso que vou subir que
colaborassem e que entre todos que
criará uma estatal cultural
[Música]
ah